Alice difficult game for you but you did
what an experienced player would do and
you managed to pull the brakes with the
white pieces tell us the story of this
game yeah
yeah like everyone would be nice but
like I was okay with the draw uh it's
just like a loss is more like
detrimental than a one is positive so I
think
um I mean I'm okay with it without I
mean I would have hoped for like
something better but after like she
surprised me in the opening
um I think I played a bit passively and
I didn't really have any chances at what
point did you start thinking okay it's
time it's time to pull the brakes I'm in
a worse position I don't feel
comfortable I don't like what's
happening on the board I think probably
after I say like after I push it before
I was like uh this I'm probably slightly
worse
um and then
so I spent I think a long time thinking
here and I played Bishop D2 uh and I I
calculated this 94 variation
um and I thought here were you worried
about this queen to G5 uh no I thought I
could take on C6 and then after Queen
takes I might have the skin of king of
one and then I'll do like H4 H5 I mean
uh it's still like not so ideal because
if I play like g3 at any point my life
squares are very weak but it's still
possible absolutely yeah yeah still not
losing by any means still a lot of work
to be done for a black on the open D and
B files good results so far for you and
tell us a bit about this game because
I'm sure you had your eyes on the Zoe
versus Carissa as well what did you
anticipate before the round to happen in
this one yeah I mean I'm not sure
because Chrissa plays the king's Indian
so it's like obviously going to be a big
fight
um so like I'm not sure I thought like
uh like when I was looking at the game
um Krista seemed to be I think slightly
better prepared she has actually like
almost twice as much time as Zoe does
yeah um and I thought like I'd probably
prefer to be black here although
especially like just with the time
situation so I think if actually of
course I went then I clinched so you're
feeling good about this one yeah I mean
I'm not sure what the objective
evaluation is but I think it's probably
easier for a person to play absolutely
if Zoe loses this one if she makes a
draw you still have to worry about the
tie breaks potentially you still have
some work to be done but if Carissa
manages to win you clinch the title yeah
well Alice great tournament so far good
uh pulling of the brakes today I have to
say great decision congratulations we'll
see you in the final round tomorrow
thank you quick question for you Alice
this is your fourth appearance in the
girls championships and obviously you're
coming into this championships with a
lot more confidence
uh tell us how you could compare your
rookie experience and what you are today
a veteran of the game yeah so I remember
like the first tournament I played in
actually I think was online
um so uh that was in 2020 and then two
years ago in 2021 I think that was
basically like my first video experience
and I think there I didn't do that while
I got like
um I just like lost a lot of games so I
mean I think um it's just like being
able to experience that even though I
didn't have particularly amazing results
the previous two years
um it was just like really good for me
to have this experience in playing in
this tournament so now I know like I
feel a lot more comfortable I guess
playing in this tournament
um compared to uh two years ago
just the feeling of experience and
comfort uh Alice uh big game tomorrow
good luck thank you absolutely